بعمر 16 عاما مراهقه بريطانيه تفقد حياتها
بسبب معاناتها مع مشاكل الوزن الزائد
بمقتلها بسبب اهمالها لوزنها والده طفله
احيله الى المحكمه بتهمه اهمال المراهقه
ومن المتوقع ان ينتهي بهم الامر بالسجن
عده سنوات
وقالت ان الفتاه كانت تعاني من السمنه
المتزايده والمرضيه التي ادت في النهايه
الى وفاتها دون ان يكترس اي من الاب او
الام ودون ان يفعلها شيئا لمواجهه السمنه
والوزن الزائد الذي تعاني منه المراهقه
فيما اعترفت الام بالقتل غير العمد
لابنتها الا انها عاده تغيرت اقوالها
لاحقا امام المحكمه فيما نفى الاب ان تغمه
منذ البدايه
يعني على العموم ما سالنا للعرب تحديدا في
مصر كيف تتعاملون مع ابنكم في حال وجود
بوادر للسمنه شراها في تناول الاكل
[موسيقى]
اكيد هابدا امن عنه
الزيوت والسمنه والحاجات المحدرجه وكده
واكله خضار وبروتينات
اللي هي بتزود له السمنه ديت يعني ما
بخليهوش ان هو حاجات شيكولاتات الحاجات
الشيبسي الكلام ده وده لازم ان انا بعوده
له من الاول
هاعملها ان انا ودي نادي مثلا يلعب فيه او
ان انا امنعوا عن الاكلات اللي بتبقى سهله
زي مثلا الفشار او الشيبسي وممكن ابدلها
بثمره او اي حاجه من الخضروات اللي بتبقى
مفيده للجسم غذائي سليم همم ابعد عن مثلا
الدهون الفاست فود لازم يلعب رياضه يمشي
على نظام غذائي سليم او نظام غذائي صحي
علشان برده هو الطفل نفسه في الوقت ده لما
يبقى عنده سنه مفرطه لما يكبر يبقى قدامه
عقبات كثير
اقدر مخليهوش ان هو ياكل اكل كثير عشان
يلعب رياضه ويعرف يتمرن يبطل اكل الشارع
وحش جدا بيسبب سنه جامده جدا وغير كده
كمان السهر
العادات اللي هي مش كويسه اللي بتسبب في
ده مثلا زي
المشروبات الغازيه
[موسيقى]
اكثر عمليات تكميم المعده في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه زادت عن 40 الف عمليه
ومعظمها للنساء الدكتور نايف العنيزي
المتخصص في جراحات السمنه اكد ان السبب
الاساسي هو الافترابات الهرمونيه وقله
الكتله العضليه وارتفاع نسبه الدهون لدى
السيدات
59% من السعوديين يعانون من السمنه اما
بالنسبه لسنه الاطفال فقد وصلت الى 6% من
من لم يلتحقوا بالمدارس بعد
تكون واضحه في السنوات الاخيره ولكن
العمليه ليست هي الحل النهائي كل ما نجري
احنا من تدخلات جراحيه وغير جراحيه هي
عباره عن وسائل مساعده نقدمها للناس في
سبيل التخلص من السمنه ولكن لا تكون هي
الحل النهائي
التخلص من السمنه هي فقط وسيله تساعدني
للتخلص ولكن هي الحل الاول والاخير هي
تغيير نظام حياه لابد الانسان يبدا يغير
في نفسه وطريقه تغذيته التغذويه والطريقه
الرياضيه
طيب دكتور نايف دكتور نايف اليوم وكانه
مساله تكميم المعده اصبحت مدراء جاء يعني
تكون الفتاه او السيده لم تصل الى الوزن
الزائد ولكن فقط لتسهيل عمليه انقاص الوزن
انتم كيف تتعاملون مع هذه الحالات
طبعا كلامك صحيح لانه اغلب الناس تقبل
عليها لمجرد
التسارع في نزول الوزن لانه بعض الناس
يقول لك انا ابغى انزل فوازن في فتره
سريعه واحنا نعرف العمليات الجراحيه هي
افضل طريقه لنزول الوزن بطريقه سريعه وهذا
يرتبط بكثير بظروف اجتماعيه لدى الشخص
اللي عندما يقبل على عمليه التكميم لكن هي
ما هي همم مفتوحه للجميع هي لها معايير
معينه همم ان احنا نمشي عليها كاطباء
وكجراحين على مستوى العالم هذه المعايير
في حال انها كانت مناسبه للشخص فيتم الاخذ
بعين الاعتبار باجراء عمليه التكميم له
لكن ان لم يكن هذا لم يكن مريض مطابق
للمعايير العالميه همم للاسف لن يكون مؤهل
لاجراء العمليه ويعطى خيارات اخرى يعني
العمليه هي واحده من الحلول لكن وليست
الحل الوحيد لاجراء العمليه هناك حلول
اخرى قد تساعد الناس خصوصا من يرغي في
يعني انقا تقريبا بنتكلم عن عشره الى 15
كيلو همم غالبا ما نلجا التدخلات الجراحيه
لانه همم في خيارات اخرى بتساعد كثير على
النزول في الوزن في مقابل همم
البعد عن العمليات الجراحيه لانها تؤدي
الى نزول اكثر من الاحتياج للمريض نفسه
طيب دكتور احنا اعتمادنا طبعا بالدرجه
الاولى على المعايير طيب اذا فشل هالشخص
دكتور في تخفيض وزنه حتى لو اتبع جميع
الحميات يعني بسبب اضطرابات هرمونيه هل
بالفعل تكميم المعده هذه العمليه ستؤدي
الى انخفاض وزنه الى 70% خلال سنتين وماذا
عن المضاعفات هل هناك مضاعفات خطيره
كالتهابات والبعض تحدث عن كذلك تتجلط الدم
في رئته
طبعا
بالنسبه للشخص الي يكون يعاني من اضطرابات
هرمونيه غالبا اييي لابد من تصحيح او علاج
الاضطرابات الهرمونيه ان وجدت ليش لانه
هذه هتستمر مع الانسان فتره اطول حتى لو
اجرى عمليات العمليات الجراحيه وعمليات
التكميم فيما بعد لابد انه يصحح
الاضطرابات الهرمونيه هذه هتساعد كثير في
نزول الانسان في فيما بعد يعني بعد اجراء
العمليه ولكن استمرار الاضطرابات
الهرمونيه استمرار وجوده حتى بعد اجراء
العمليه قد لا تعطي همم المساحه الكافيه
للنزول في الوزن كما همم يتوقع لذلك من
الشيء الرئيسي المهم علاج الاضطرابات قبل
القدوم على عمليه التكمي قبل الشروع في
عمليه التكميم واا بعدها همم بالامكان عمل
عمليه التكميم بكل رياحيه بالنسبه
للمضاعفات المضاعفات احنا نعرف انه اي
عمليه جراحيه تجرى ليست همم محميه من
المضاعفات هناك مضاعفات لكن بنسب بسيطه
ومختلفه تعتمد من عمليه الى اخرى هذا
مضاعفات عالميه او الارقام اللي احنا
نعطيها والنسب هذه عالميه
كثير من الناس يتخوف من التسريب واحنا
نعرف هو الحاج
المزعجه كثير من المقبلين على العمليات
التكميم ولكن الان احنا نتكلم في 2022
نسبه التسريب لا تتجاوز اثنين في المئه
كانت السابقه اعلى من هذه النسبه لكن مع
تطور اللي هو ال- ال- ال- التقنيات
الجراحيه في اجراء العمليات بدء التقريب
بالنسبه
للتجلطات نسبتها اقل من واحد في المئه
يعني رقم رقم مخيف يعني 59% من السعوديين
يعانون من السمنه شو صاير ما الذي اوصلهم
الى هذا الحال
[موسيقى]
طبعا هذه الدراسه يعني كانت عن طريق وزاره
الصحه في عام 2020 النسبه هذه طبعا مخيفه
وعاليه واكيد كثير من المجتمعات تحال على
مستوى العالم تحارب السمنه احنا ليش لانه
نعرف مشاكلها ومضاعفاتها والاشياء اللي
تبنى على السمنه وايش ال ال ال ال يعني
حتى ارتفاع الوفيات بسبب السمنه بدات تكون
ارقام ماهوله يعني عندك
71% من كنسبه من الوفيات هي مرتبطه
بالسمنه واداء السكري واحد فاصله اثنين
همم مليون يعني مليون و200 شخص عالمي
يتوفون بسبب السمنه فهذه الارقام كلها
مخيفه نعزيها كثير همم
التغذيه التغذيه عند الانسان الناس بدات
يعني احنا الان مع تطور التكنولوجيا مع
التطور
همم كل شيء عندنا صار في الحياه سهل وبسيط
يعني نحصل عليه بشكل همم يعني واحنا
جالسين في مكاتبنا في بيوتنا في اي مكان
فالتغذيه هذه امرها يعني بدها يدخل في في
حيز جدا ضيق وبالتالي بدات الناس يعني
تاخذها بطريقه سهله وبسيطه وهذه تبعاتها
كانت لخبطت التغذيه التي التغذيه التي
تكون عند الانسان بالاضافه الى الكسل وعدم
الالتزام بالرياض هذه السبب بين الرئيسيات
اللي تمثل انا اشوفها دائما اكثر من 80
الى 85% من سبب ارتفاع نسبه السمنه في
المجتمعات بشكل عام شكرا جزيلا دكتور نايف
يعني